foreign
honorable members
indeed the bulk of the discussion in the
European Council was about the important
topic of energy
and the magnitude of the energy crisis
calls absolutely for both a sense of
urgency
and a strategic foresight
and I think we should not forget where
we came from
we have made more progress than we
thought ever possible
because we should not forget that at the
beginning of this war since the
beginning of this war Putin has cut 80
percent of the pipeline gas supplied to
the European Union 80 percent and in
only eight months we have managed to
replace most of it
we have more than doubled for example
the Imports of LNG from the United
States from 20 to BCM last year to 48
BCM this year so far
this has among others made it possible
for us to fill our storages today by 95
percent
and at the same time we have reduced our
gas consumption by 15 percent
I have not forgotten at the beginning of
this war how Putin tried to put pressure
on us through energy and how some feared
that we would have blackouts in Europe
When The War started
so honorable members not only did this
dark scenario not materialize
but now we are fully prepared for the
winter
and crucially gas prices have dropped by
roughly two-thirds compared to the peak
that we had in August
so Putin really tried everything to
bring us down to our knees he completely
failed we have all played our part to
make this happen and I think we can be
proud of this
foreign foreign
it's marked
foreign
stopped
in Detroit
that's Heist in a greatness current is
winter because
and therefore honorable members
as I was describing these three risks we
are now getting prepared to tackle these
potential risks
but we should not forget that in doing
so we are also setting the right course
for the future
because our choices today will determine
whether we have the right energy we need
for 2023 and Beyond
so this is why today I would like to
focus on two topics that are crucial
the first topic is Renewables
it is no exact
exaggeration to say that we stand at a
Crossroads
we can decide right now that either we
ignore the lessons that we have learned
in this crisis
and fall again into the Trap of a carbon
lock in for the future
all we use this crisis to LEAP frock
into clean energy
and this is not only good for our
climate but it is also good for our
security and our depend Independence
especially in times when gas is and will
stay scarce commodity
the good news is in this scenario that
we are ready to accelerate
by the end of the year we will have
achieved the largest growth in
Renewables in the history of the
European Union
this is almost a furthest 50 gigawatt
that we will have additionally as
Renewables in the market which is double
what we had added last year
and we could accelerate even more
there are countless renewable projects
that are just waking waiting to be
approved
some could deliver cheap energy
immediately in a matter of weeks or
months
I'm thinking for example of solar panels
on existing buildings or I'm thinking of
repowering of wind parks
but we know that far too many of these
projects are stuck because of long long
permitting procedures
now our new
renewable energy directive that you have
already voted on in plenary
addresses this topic
but it will take time
well over a year
before this directive is translated into
National Law by all member states
so with these extraordinary
circumstances our citizens and
industries are facing we do not have the
luxury of time
and this is why today we are proposing a
new emergency regulation under article
one to two
to immediately speed up permitting for
renewable energy projects with a rapid
impact
this proposal will be limited in time
and scope
it will be in line
with what you have voted on
and it will be Bridging the Gap until
the new renewable energy directive comes
into Force
and by doing so
we can unlock a myriad of renewable
projects already in the next 12 months
so this is a very decisive move right
now
according to the calculations by the
International Energy agency
we could replace 14 billion cubic meter
of gas already next year
and that's almost half of our potential
Gap I was just describing just by
speeding up
the permitting of these projects
this is realistic
and we all can pull off this together
and I think we should grab the
opportunity right now
deputy
Empire
University European
Commons
exceptions
difficulty
is
[Music]
foreign
foreign
ergy
is
honorable members
this is where we power EU comes into
play
because if we boost the financial
Firepower of repower EU
we will ensure that all member states
have the possibility to realize these
critical Investments
in other words
this would give every member State the
same opportunity to prepare for the
future
and at the same time some fiscal space
to support vulnerable households and
businesses so let's go for it
and this work is also helpful against
the backdrop of an intensifying Global
clean tech race
because it will keep Europe attractive
for industry let me be very clear I do
welcome Global competition
this drives Innovation it enhances
efficiency and it ensures progress
at the same time in order to be
effective This Global competition has to
be fair
we need a Level Playing Field we do not
want to see Market distortions or
discrimination against our companies
so let's make sure that this is not a
race to the bottom but this is a race to
the top for our climate and for our
industry that's what Europe stands for
and I know that's also what this
Parliament stands for Long Live Europe
and many things
thank you very much
president Von the lion I give the floor
now to the representatives of the
different political groups starting